Irina Meyer, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you. Thank you very much
for having me. I love your show.
Thank you.
You have such a non-linear path
that I can't wait to dive deep
and understand how your values
are progressing you through your
different life decisions.
But, you know, as a brief intro,
which will do no service
to the incredible things you've done.
First of all, you're an Emmy Award winner.
Let's put that out there.
I can't wait to hear what that's about.
But you actually started,
or you didn't start
you progressed through,
financial institutions
like Bank of America.
You're a huge investor in
I think, international investor
because you speak six languages.
I have to understand what that's about.
Irina, talk to me.
Who are you?
How do you do all this stuff?
I don't know.
I just do things which the most normal,
the most natural for me.
Which means
I always do the thing that
I feel is the right thing.
I walk away from the people
who are wrong people,
and I think that's very important.
And I follow the passion that I have.
And I always, at any point in time,
make sure that I give back.
So any time I fail and
or I'm a bad situation,
I push forward.
Any time I win, I have to pause
and make sure that
I share my success with other people
who also need a break.
So that's kind of how I roll.
And also, I learn all the time.
I never stop learning.
I love it. I just love it. Okay.
So, talk to me, how do you start
from a place like Bank of America
and then move on to a place like ABC?
Motion pictures? Win an Emmy?
What's it about?
So, I was working
and indeed in the technology group,
I was at the Bank of America
and it's actually in the beginning
was countrywide.
And I was working doing the
technical risk assessments
for their central group
which means for their headquarters.
All their projects of the value
above $20 million of business impact
will go for me.
Then when 2008 happened,
and I just was seeing what was
unfolding with the countrywide
that no matter how good
the two hundred people
around me were,
that the company was deeply corrupt
and created such an incredibly
devastating trickle effect
of contributing to it in the country.
And even though I just was promoted
four months prior to AVP,
I walked away
because I never wanted,
and I didn't have another job lined up,
because they just
I knew that was not right.
And that was me walking away
from the wrong people,
and I didn't want to create
any kind of explanation for myself
why I should stay.
So Irina on that note.
So, you mentioned right at the offset
that you're guided by your values
and that guides your non traditional
non-linear path.
What are these core values
that you are addressing here?
Absolutely.
So, you need to make sure that your work
being contributed to something good.
Greater good.
You do not give away your work
for something which is meaningless
or have some kind of short term
pragmatic effect.
It's just not for me.
Whenever I work,
it's really need to be
to make better the social environment.
It needs to be towards the creativity.
It needs to be for the better
of the of the people.
If it does not go there,
it just, it stops for me.
And I know that I have quite
significant success,
and I have my personal capital fund
that I run and it's international,
but I never followed what will be my
short term or even
mid-term financial gain
because money is gonna follow you
when you're doing the right thing
and you'll work with the right people.
And it doesn't have to be immediate.
But it always will.
That's my experience.
Inspiring. Okay.
So, moving on to digital media
and television.
What is this industry that I,
I don't know anything about it.
So, you go.
What does it mean even digital media
and making those innovations over there?
Of course. So, digital media progresses.
So what is it today in 2020
is very different when what it was in 2010
So, when I was there, digital media
it is the way to for the people
to connect with whatever they love.
So it doesn't have to be
for the network television.
I was working for ABC,
but only digital media.
That's me.
That whenever there were Oscars,
and I was running Oscar's production
for there three years,
is to bring the experience to the people.
Not make it,
not live it as an elite.
You know, you just there
in on some kind of magazine cover
Angelina Jolie and you have no relation.
You create those bridges.
You connect it via your laptop,
your computer,
and many of the IOS devices,
Androids.
So you bring that to people.
How to make that relevant to you?
And every time and every day
of working in digital media,
that's what we were doing.
... about Oscars.
Make sure you are there.
That means that the cameras
that I would supervise
to put in, they ...
every person from millions
connecting to the livestream.
They had an impression that
they can move it at any point.
And they can be there
and watch what people do
during their stars,
during the commercial breaks.
And bring it home.
And that is really fascinating
because that's what we want.
We do not want to just
be on the outskirts.
We want to be part of this show.
And that's what the digital will do.
So, what are some of the challenges
that you faced as you were trying
to innovate this concept?
So, what does that even mean
for me to sit at home
and be present at the Oscars?
For example, you are invited.
That's the thing.
You receive the golden envelope.
You're invited.
You can choose to go and see
where the stars take champagne.
You can decide what dress a trophy girl,
I am not being obnoxious
it's ... usual name
called trophy girl.
The girl who brings the
who brings the Oscar.
That's the position.
What will she be wearing?
And that will be competition
among 10 different upcoming
totally unknown designers.
- Unbelievable
And people can be present
at the catwalk which will be
done before.
And the winner will be announced
during this time.
That means that on the red carpet,
there will be ... digital media hosts.
By the way, we had our booth
right next to Oprah's.
And then where we will be talking
for our fans, for our viewers
from home.
Not necessarily just bringing
more people to the ABC channel
so that the ABC channel
will sell more ads.
It's for the people who can just
log on their phone and
or on their tablet
and just be there.
And their questions will be answered.
Amazing. But that's radically different
from being an investor.
You're investing in early stage startups
yet here you are being a creative.
You're running creativity to how
to integrate the at home experience
with something as amazing as the Oscars.
And by the way, you got the Emmy in 2011,
and what was that for?
For innovation and digital media?
Yes, it was outstanding achievement
in interactive media.
And that was, the product was
Oscars digital experience.
So, that's the whole package that we did
and that we were unfolding
for the five months prior to the show.
We recorded,
we created for television shows,
for web presence. We did
meetings with the stars.
With the nominated stars.
There were designer contests.
There was sweepstakes.
There were many things prior to the event.
So, the whole package of it
was Oscars digital experience.
And we rolled it out on IOS only
it was barely eight months
after iPod was out.
And it took I believe three years
until something similar
were rolled out by somebody else
which was MTV later on.
So, yeah, it was actually a big deal
from technological perspective.
I worked with over 20 different
contractors in addition to over 15
of different internal groups for ABC
and the infrastructure groups at Disney
which is a parent company of ABC.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
Okay. Let's move on
to your two investments.
You're running an early stage fund.
You're investing internationally,
which is unique in its own way
because most venture capital funds,
especially early stage, they're focused
on a certain geographical region.
Yet you're branching out.
And is that because
you speak six languages?
Is that a part of it?
No, I'm not sure
because I learn languages
for years before they eventually
become useful.
Because it is.
So, it helps when it comes.
But I am once again,
I avoid this pragmatic effect.
Why don't I learn German
so I can invest in Switzerland?
It happens in a similar way.
Or why do I learn Mandarin Chinese
for the last 10 years
and it's only a year ago when I became
a board member for a company
which is doing development in China.
So it comes eventually together
but it's not because of that.
And I agree with you
this is not conventional.
I'm the only person in my company.
The fund is my personal.
I don't have any LPs.
And for an individual,
a one woman operation to say,
you know US is not enough.
I made only last year
six investments in Israel.
And I invested in a Swiss company
and I'm planning to do more.
I'm a member of two groups
in Zurich and in Zug.
And yeah, it is,
but there is a method to the madness.
I am not just being
trying to overextend myself.
I plan specifically.
Let's say when I go to Israel.
I have a plan.
What is it?
What type of company interests me?
What type of innovation?
What groups I need to work?
I know what proportion of my portfolio
I want to be dedicated
to this specific area
which is med device
life science in Israel
which I find absolutely extraordinary.
And that I wanted to be
within about 25 to 30 to 33%
of my portfolio.
And I just work diligently
for a very long time
before I trigger my investments,
but whenever they are ready,
I'm very decisive
and I'm just going
and I'm executing it.
Same thing that I would do
in Switzerland.
And recently I invested even
in a company out of
Sofia, Bulgaria.
My very first east
European company.
How did you even find these companies
because the deal flow is its own struggle.
There's so many early stage VCs
around the world now.
I don't know how many there are
in Eastern Europe,
but around the world and Israel
and the US of course, there is a lot.
So how do you go and find those deals
so that when you want to be decisive
and execute, you actually have
access to the best deals?
So that is an absolutely
wonderful question.
And that is the biggest issue
I think that exists with private investors
is the access to the deal flow
and be able to see through it correctly.
And I've been very fortunate in the fact
that I've been able to create
an extraordinary network.
And because I'm never afraid
to walk away from something
that doesn't work or
being very outspoken
when something is subpar,
that I have really wonderful collaborators.
And I spend huge amount of my time,
perhaps over 80% of my time,
doing pro bono work
for other investors.
When I do that,
and I do not ask for any,
and that goes back to my core values.
And I do not ask for shares
or payment of any kind.
I will get back the most interesting deals
these people will be working on.
And they will be sharing it with me
that they might be even reluctant
to do with somebody else.
And it's not only with private individuals.
VCs, like partners in VC Firms,
will reach out to me and say,
"Hey Irina, I came across that.
Our fund is investing and
would you like to have
some space in the round?"
And that I think is -
It's all about relationships.
- greater for me versus many other
private investors in the space.
I'm very lucky in this way.
So it's all about the relationships
and it sounds like, again,
the pro bono work that you're doing,
and all these different experiences,
and the values that you're exuding
they're not about getting
something in the short term.
You think, you're saying I'm
operating my life in the long term,
and if I'm kind
and if I'm helpful to others now,
I'm not expecting anything in return.
But you know,
accumulatively over years,
these relationships go both ways.
And it's not just that they're helping me,
they want me to be in a partnership
with them because they know
that my values are true and honest.
Yeah. And oftentimes
it doesn't come through,
and I'm completely okay with that.
Sometimes people just consume
the piece of work I've done
and then that's it.
And you know what?
I never have hard feelings about it
because I know that I'm
doing the right thing.
And that is it.
And the access to the most interesting,
innovative company,
to the COOs who need mentorship.
Who need help.
Who need introduction.
And it's everything
that I do is collaborative.
Every single thing.
I never just find a gem and says,
"Okay. That is just for me.
I hope nobody hears about it.
I don't want to do any work
for them because it would be free."
No, I will tell about it and I will help.
Sometimes I do work for the C
for the company,
employees, CEO, for years
without even being an official adviser
because that is how I can help
my companies to gain value and to come
to the next level of financing.
Reaching the new audience that
I am not a passive investor.
And I think it's also,
it helps me to get much better results
than probably on average in the space.
Amazing.
Irina, what is it about languages
that you love so much?
How do you get to learn six languages?
And what are those six, by the way?
Well, my mother language,
my mother tongue is Russian.
And then obviously it's English.
French. I was in Paris for a year,
and I learned French literature
and French language in Paris.
And then I speak German.
And that is my most recent language.
I started learning Chinese
back in 2006 or so.
I am quite fluent in Mandarin.
I speak Spanish fluently,
which definitely helps.
And I don't know, maybe I missed
something but -
Well next one needs to be Hebrew
of course.
Of course.
But I love it
because it breaks the barriers
between me and other people
and other cultures,
and it makes my life richer
because I can read,
I can watch TV in whatever language,
I can travel and I can talk to people
and I am very people oriented.
And I feel like my world is brighter
and bigger and happier
and than it would be otherwise.
I love it.
Irina, what is the one thing
you're most passionate about?
What gets you so excited
every single morning when you
wake up about the work that you do?
About the work that I do?
Yes, it is I feel like an individual
have an opportunity to make a
huge effect on the society at large,
and I'm not talking about
one country's society.
It is we, I feel like I can
I am making a difference.
Whether it is from my volunteering work
for the Amy Foundation.
Or whether it is by mentoring somebody
who brings a new way of popularizing
something that was used to be
available only to elite.
Who bring in the medication,
the new molecules
that is gonna save lives
and prevent suffering.
From women suffering
from breast cancers,
from early diagnosis of the oral cancers.
And it also make difference for the life
of individual entrepreneurs who strive
with their dreams or
in their creative side,
well everything is creative,
but in the television arts
for the young people
out of Alabama
Mississippi
who want to be producers in Hollywood.
You want to give them that chance.
And when you can,
by finding for them an internship
in with one of the studios,
you feel like that day was a good day.
And it's just for them.
It's all been nothing for me.
But it feels more than anything else
that I can receive in the form
of payments, talk or something else.
Irina, inspiring, inspiring.
Right before we leave,
I can't believe 20 minutes are already up.
I need three words that best describe you.
And I want to thank you for really
the generous time,
that you've given me here.
So, that is a good question.
So, number one will be decisive.
So, I am capable of making decisions.
So, that would be definitely.
Passionate.
Passionate will be the second one
cause if I'm not passionate,
I just don't do it.
And the third would be
I don't know why, but that's what people
seem to differentiate me from others.
I know no fear.
So I'm absolutely fearless.
There is no such a thing
that somebody can scare me.
It just doesn't work.
Decisive. Passionate. Fearless.
Irina, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
We didn't even talk about J-Ventures
and how I love collaborating there
but we'll leave that for another time.
Thank you for everything.
Really inspiring. Just thank you.
Thank you. Thank you very, very much.
And I hope to collaborate sometime
soon with perhaps my own venture.
Would love to. Please think of me
when you're building something new.
Thank you. Take care.
Bye bye.